I spent three days with some of the top
YouTubers on the planet collectively the
room had over 300 million subscribers
there was only six people there one of
the things that I learned that was most
important was level of effort when these
guys were showing me that they had 200
different thumbnails that they were
split testing and picking between or the
fact that they would pay a cartoon
company to make cartoonized versions of
the video before they would dedicate
full resources at twenty thousand
dollars a pop and they make two or three
versions of it they call them previous
before they would actually make their
full video that's when I realized that
the same universal law of work applies
across everything and it became clear to
me why my videos only hit 250 000 when
these guys are hitting 200 million